foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined here by my good friend
George Campbell and we are taking your
calls on money and life and
relationships and work whatever you got
going on in your life I am confident we
have an opinion on it
um advice and opinions are two very
different things correct I will not give
you advice so I'll give you my I'll give
you my opinion give us a buzz at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five good grief man the Lobby's
packed out there I think these are
leftovers from our smart conference
event that we just had over the weekend
I don't think they're leftovers I think
I mean in a bad way I mean they don't
want to go back to you know Coeur
d'Alene or wherever they came from
they're like Nashville's where it's at
let's hang out here but we did have a
great event Friday and Saturday John
with over 2000 of our newest friends
yeah fantastic and it's good to see
everybody still hanging out with us
thank you all so so much all right let's
go out to
um Dane in Sacramento what's up Dane
hi
George and John can you hear me we got
you man what's up great hi uh appreciate
you everything you guys do for us uh
question is um I've been working the
baby steps for a number of years
particularly baby step six I've been
paying on my house trying to pay it off
for about seven years I'm at a point
where I have about 29 000 left on my
mortgage and I have a basically
emergency fund and some just cash around
thirty five thousand dollars and so I
can you know smell the Finish Line I'm
kind of like well should I use you know
pay off my mortgage and have a have a
lower emergency fund for a while to
build it back up to get out of depth or
should I just uh kind of keep uh keep
doing what I've been doing way to go
dude yeah what is what does lower mean
well I mean I think it's just uh you
know I would thirty five thousand is
basically my emergency fund so it'd be
down to six thousand dollars and that
frightens me you're so close
I can feel it for him how many months is
this emergency fund currently of
expenses
oh it's probably I mean it's between
three and six okay probably by like four
I'd say four how much do you make a
month
uh uh that's what's uh I gross uh about
9 500. a month
yes so either way we're talking two
months from now this thing's gone three
months from now
uh how close would you be yeah if you
just followed the same Pace you were
going without touching the emergency
fund how many more months till it's paid
off with just extra payments from your
paychecks yeah I mean I was thinking
kind of end of the year would be my you
know wrong the the definite right okay
my personal preference is that you keep
minimum three months of expenses
anything beyond that you throw at the
house I'm good with
okay and I would I would probably if I
mean I I've I can just feel it man for
you and so I'm trying to figure out a
way to make this to accelerate this
maybe you look at three months and you
also at the same time you say I'm Gonna
Leave three months in the account but
I'm gonna go Bare Bones those three
months We're not gonna go out we're not
gonna we're gonna go back to baby step
one just for just for 90 days and we're
gonna paint this sucker off right now if
you if you think you could do that
um some people pay their house off and
they just kind of have a freebie month
and they just kind of go bananas and
then others um just walk around in a
daze for a few months because they can't
believe how good it all feels and so I
I'm with I'm I'm I don't know George I'm
kind of splitting the difference with
you well you're you're a risk taker John
you're like oh let's do it I just hate
waiting I hate wait but he's waited
seven years with such diligence and
patience and the last thing I want is
from to do this like Hail Mary and then
the HVAC goes out and he doesn't even
have enough in the emergency fund to
cover it
that's this that's the part that I my
brain goes fun ruiner.org.net man here's
the other thing though your expenses
will get lower without a house payment
by the principal in the interest you'll
still have taxes and insurance so factor
that into the emergency fund and that
will give you kind of a new number for
that three months and once you have that
amount over the limit you can pay it off
write that check all right
George sorry Junior facts all right
let's go out to Amanda in Kansas City
what's up Amanda
hello
how are you I I literally couldn't be
better how are you
doing well excellent what's up um so my
question today
um so technically we're in baby step two
um I started listening to you guys last
fall and
um I'm kind of backtracking
um so we've been kind of doing like all
the steps at once and
um at this point
um I have one big expense that needs to
be paid off it's my vehicle and I'm
having a hard time justifying doing it
well you're you're trying to do all the
steps at once
well yeah I've kind of I'm kind of like
backtracked now and I'm I'm trying to do
baby stuff too what happens what do they
call it when you hit all of the steps I
feel like going up the stairs and you
hit them all at once what does that mean
you've done
you face playing it you ate it don't do
don't do them all at once that's the
falling down all right um George save
this thing why pay off the car
yeah well what's your car payment
um well it's like 560 a month but I've
been paying more on it
um why would you not pay it off so the
question is if I was able to hand you
560 a month for the rest of your life
wouldn't you rather take that than pay
it to A lender with interest
um but if I could use it for other
things while I'm
using that money that logic makes no
sense right now you're in the whole 560.
I'm up 560. who has more options me or
you
so okay so here's here's my thoughts on
this so it's a pretty low interest rate
which I know that's like
that doesn't it's not supposed to matter
nobody cares versus more stupid okay
keep telling us about Amanda's plan keep
going if I if I pay it off then I'm
going to feel like I'm constantly car
shopping I'm like always looking at cars
this feels like you have a nice car what
car is this
um it's a it's a Telluride oh that's a
sick whip one of those things 60 Grand
um and I I got a better deal on it than
that what do you make a year
uh between my husband and I were at 2 30
a year you're crushing it why do you
need a car payment
here I I I I heard what she was saying
you want to keep a fight you're charging
yourself 560 dollars because you can't
close an internet browser
okay you have to you have to deal with
the fact that you think that your joy
and happiness are somewhere other than
where you are sitting
and the moment you're just chasing
happiness you're chasing it it's elusive
you will never forget this
is I feel like so we've got funds like
I've got funds and rental rental account
stuff like that that I don't really want
to touch but I have a
emergency fund you know like our you
know three to six months I have that
I could deplete that and pay this off
that's exactly what you should do and
there's a 99.9 chance you will not do it
we can't help people who don't want the
help and it sounds like Amanda's plan is
better than a proven plan that's helped
millions of people become wealthy you
like you like spending five to six
hundred bucks a month to have your
account numbers look nice over here and
your internet browser down over here you
got to grow up and be an adult you got
to grow up for being adult y'all make
too much money to be this broke pay off
your stupid car for crying out loud and
then get on with your life and make you
got it tell your money where to go
instead of tell you ride Amanda
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by George
Campbell we're taking calls on money and
work and life and relationships whatever
you got going on we are here for it
um let's see here hey George uh uh you
got an ad mention go ahead I do and I
just mentioned we had an incredible
smart conference event this weekend at
our brand new Ramsey Event Center and it
was so awesome that we're gonna do it
again but this time we are heading to
Chicago for a smart conference weekend
so if you're a new listener or you
haven't been to one of our Live Events
smart conference is our biggest event
it's every single one of our
personalities just crushing it on in
their Lanes doing their thing John got a
standing o I don't think it was a dry
eye in the room John well I I paid them
that makes more sense you pay 2 000
people a dollar each to do a standing
out hey so some of us have it George
some of us have it well if you want to
join thousands of other people just like
you who are following the babies steps
whether you're just getting started or
you've been doing it a while or you need
some encouragement smart conference is
the place to be we've had tons of people
tell us how motivated they are how this
is exactly what they needed to get back
on the plan or how they finally got
their spouse on board so if you want to
leave with a plan to improve every area
of your life your money your mental
health your career your relationships
join us all on September 15th and 16th
in Chicago it's going to be Dave Ramsey
Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney Ken Coleman
Jade warshaw and myself for this two-day
event of a lifetime plus you're gonna
have a chance to meet us we love going
out there during the breaks and and
signing stuff and taking photos maybe
we'll even do another smart money happy
hour live recording which was a big hit
wasn't the fun doesn't stop there a lot
of surprises maybe John deloney up there
ripping a solo on a guitar they don't
know I'm gonna bring the bagpipes this
time we're going to rock that's worth
the ticket price alone and this event
always sells out and it starts at just
79 which is insane for a two-day event
like this so go to ramsaysolutions.com
events get your tickets today and even
if you're on Chicago we've had people
travel from all over the country to be
here so make plans September 15th 16th
in Chicago ramseysolutions.com events
all right let's go to Haley in
Providence Rhode Island what's up Haley
hi can you hear me with Crystal Clarity
what's up
okay thank you for to call I'm really
grateful for both your work
um okay my thing is should we remain in
a house but our budget would be like
razor thin for the next 12 to 15 years
so yeah here's my question you
absolutely a hundred percent know the
answer to that so what is the thing
going on inside your soul that makes
coming to that realization and then
doing what you have to do so challenging
um so the challenge is at the market is
so uncertain and I don't think that we
could take a leap to us we would want to
downsize the size and the scale of our
home but it doesn't seem like the
numbers are making sense
um
so what's your take-home package
okay so our take-home pay is about 110
um my husband has a handyman business on
the side all right so there's there's
sometimes we can make more okay and
what's your mortgage
okay so the mortgage is 2500 right now a
thousand dollars of it is covered by my
mom I've been her caretaker
um we built her in law and she's getting
she's declining she needs a facility
care
and we don't feel comfortable without
her rent
covering this like the size the
utilities the upkeep of the house well
based on what you told me your mortgage
is about 27 of your take-home pay
yeah the numbers here don't scream fire
to me so where is the actual problem do
you guys have other piles of dead
hanging around
we uh we just have my car which we're
working on paying off but
um I guess where I'm I'm at is that the
amount of like replacing the deck
replacing the windows that number for us
is takes away from like
time with our family to cover
I feel like we're too thin well those
are one-time repairs that we can do over
a period of time
that's not a monthly expense
so if we just set a small sinking fund
let's say you know 400 bucks a month
that's about five grand a year goes to
towards home repairs
would that solve this problem
I just feel like there's other pieces
here because you guys make 10 grand a
month yeah there's something your
mortgage 2500. 7 500 going
do you just want to not live in this
house anymore
I'm a good those are good weeks of
handyman stuff that's those are those
are when all the stars align listen
listen listen listen
sure you don't need any permission to
leave to move
okay so how do we know where we're gonna
go go rent a house go rent a house
what's the fears underneath all this
what's wrong with you going to rent
somewhere for a year
um so if we were to run it would be
about the same price point that we're
paying now
but you have no big issue was that you
don't want to do all the repairs and
you're paying for all these things and
it's stressing you guys out
you're describing to us a pot of boiling
water and you're in it and we're telling
you to jump out and you're like yeah but
it's hot over there and it's cold over
there and so we're like you're painting
this picture that you can't win and I I
just don't buy it there's there's got to
be another solution it's not going to be
a comfortable one but there's got to be
a solution you just you just circle the
wagons on yourself and you have nowhere
to go
right yeah that's where yes
I think you guys need to do a written
monthly budget and you need to figure
out what your low months are what your
normal months are what your high months
are and start planning for those low
months and everything that's gravy on
top we can set aside you have an
emergency fund right now
we do we have three months okay so that
should give you a level of peace that if
something goes down we have an emergency
fund to cover it and so I want you to
get away from this razor thin mentality
where there could be one thing that just
takes us out because that is stressful
that's going to keep you up at night and
let me tell you this it's not uncommon
when someone you love is hurting and
struggling
and you are seeing end of life
transitions happen right before you
you're a part of them it's almost
surreal the decisions you're having to
make the conversations you're having
um the documents you're signing and
when we do that on a foundation of chaos
when you and your husband aren't aligned
or your kids aren't and you aren't
connected or you're worried about your
finances or this house just has some
some
some memories in it that you're ready to
move on from
your body will just start sounding the
alarms and it's going to make everything
around you feel like it's the end of the
world you're going to feel pegged into a
corner boxed into a corner that you
can't get out of and it's just simply
not true you just got to turn the lights
on
and so some of this is going to be
solved by you sitting down and grieving
the fact
that your mom's moving from your home
possibly to or her last place
that she's ever going to live
and that stinks and it's hard and it's
heartbreaking and it's sad and it's
something to be grieved
and you and your husband may have had a
cool house and y'all had all these
dreams of fixing it up and doing it all
nice and it's just become a nightmare
even though it financially it works out
that's all that's okay
but just grieve that we had this picture
in our head we thought it was gonna be
this and now it's gonna be something
else
and I'll tell you the year me and my
wife sold our house I actually had to
bring a check to closing because we sold
it at a loss
and we moved into a a dorm a two-bedroom
apartment with a toddler
just to let the Smoke Clear to pay our
debts off and to recalibrate our
marriage and our life and all that stuff
it's the best year we it's the best
investment we ever made it changed our
life in a bunch of different ways it
revealed some chaos that has taken years
to um to heal from but it was worth it
and for others just running from your
house great your problems and your
challenges and your grief is going to go
with you so that may not be the solution
here but it sounds like you're just
circling these challenges instead of
sitting on a kitchen table with your
husband and a yellow pad and a pen and
just saying we've got a we can't run
from these storms we can't run from the
smoke we gotta head straight in
does that sound right
yeah that sounds right
Haley hang on the line I'm going to send
you our every dollar budgeting app it's
going to help you make a plan for these
dollars I'm selling the car before I
sell the house and if that doesn't give
you enough margin then we can consider
our next move but I think John's right
this isn't a financial question this is
largely emotional and relational and
we're cheering you on either way this is
the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back this is the Ramsay show and
we have two beautiful people over there
on the debt free stage chukes in
Virginia
welcome welcome to Nashville where are
you where are you in from Dallas Texas
or Fort Worth the the right side
of the earth and so uh how much have you
paid off
four hundred and eighteen thousand
dollars
man you're coming in hot okay uh how
long did it take you it took us about
four years and 10 months
and I always love George I always love
what someone says about and then they
give you exactly how long I was waiting
for the days to come in what was your
range of income during that time
well we started off at about 300 000 and
then we kicked it up to about 550 000
but uh funny story this is actually our
second uh debt free scream so we
actually paid off our debt in I think
2017 uh we paid off about 418 000 at
that time it was student loans and you
know credit cards and a bunch of other
stuff and then we got a house which is
what we paid off here so this is
you came full circle yeah you took out
almost half a million dollars in
Consumer Debt paying for the pass and
now you're building for the future yep
and you knocked out another freaking
mortgage yeah yeah you guys are
incredible what do you guys do for a
living
so I own a couple businesses um one of
them I'm actually an executive career
coach so I help mid-level professionals
find jobs you know within three months
or less George wants to talk to you
after the show looking for a job yeah
clearly you're very good at it yeah and
then also on a learning company so we
work with a bunch of different online
universities where we do course room
management and teaching and things like
that and then
and I'm on their training learning
development uh Team so been there now
for eight years and it has been a
blessing it's been wonderful so yes
extraordinary Okay so
um let's just stick with the mortgage
what set you on this path what made you
decide you know what let's just pay the
sucker off
yeah um so um
take all the way back how did you get
involved in this crazy cult that we have
over here yeah it's a good cult
um so
I got married
uh like tons of student loans and so we
both knew like this is crazy like how
could you possibly live life with this
magnitude of student loans and so he has
a PHD I have an MBA that's like 19 years
of higher education and the bill
reflected every single penny of it
um so honestly we were just kind of like
in a shock factor and we my parents and
my sister are Avid fans of Dave Ramsey
from years and years ago like 20 years
ago and so he was always a book like on
the Shelf you know and he was always a
part of the conversations in my family's
life and so when we got married I said
well hey have you checked out Dave
Ramsey have you checked him out he seems
like you know solid solid Solitude and
he checked him out and he like felt like
nosedive into all of his content I was
like I think you're taking this way
so
um so he was like committed he was in it
and then the next thing I know we are
like in the thick of paying off our
student loans like with gazal intensity
as damn Dave refers to and um so that
was quite the journey but that started
off us with like the student loan part
of it well whenever we were finished
that out we enjoyed all of like maybe
eight weeks of this Serenity of debt
free well I wanted a house and I wanted
like we were moving into the next stages
of her life and so look at him
yep and so um you know Dave talks about
paying off the house like over you know
a period of time it's not the first
thing you know but it's like you're
gonna be intense you're gonna be
dedicated and so I was like okay we're
gonna do 15 years you know like we're
gonna you know do the extra payments
well my husband came to me and he was
just like no we need to clear this off
the books completely he was like I don't
want to you know I don't want to
gradually do this like I want to go back
back in like intensity and so I was like
oh my gosh I wasn't quite there yet but
I knew like with his personal conviction
that we just couldn't live life
um with a mortgage on the books like for
us like that was a decision like I just
knew that I knew that I knew he wasn't
going to rest he wasn't going to settle
until we got it off the books and so
that started us on this nearly five-year
journey of paying off our you know very
beautiful home so
about 720 000. wow yeah yeah we bought
it at 465 and yeah put our 10 down and
then of course just worked at it I
wanted to pay it off a lot sooner but
that was our biggest money fights you
know I know that's some of the questions
you guys asked but you know it was
mainly how much money are we going to
put towards the house you know and so
she kind of want to you know wanted to
relax a little bit I kind of wanted to
just move just let's pay this off now
but we had to find a happy medium yeah
it was very much doing it in style I was
like can we do this in style can we do
this in comfort and he was like yeah if
you're comfortable with 90 miles per
hour like that's how we're gonna do it
and I was like okay well you blinked and
you're here yeah I mean most people have
mortgages for 30 years you guys are like
nah we're good less than five years this
thing's gone and now I mean are you are
you baby steps millionaires now we are
we are yes so we have about 466
000 in retirement and about eighty
thousand dollars in cash savings
incredible and so about 1.2 million net
worth not that we're counting but yeah
yeah 1.2 so most people here's what the
objection I hear well Dave Ramsey's
great but he's for broke people you guys
don't seem close to broke and yet you
Dove full head on into this stuff what
do you say to those people
because listen let's be honest at your
income you had people in your life
asking you why are you driving oh 100
what are you doing why don't you come
out leveraging debt and you don't need
to get rid of that car payment yeah yeah
well
you want me to go okay so when we first
started I mean we're making about maybe
a hundred thousand dollars
um together and um you know and of
course you know we just worked really
really really really really really
really hard I mean I was working 14 hour
days even longer than that um sometimes
seven days a week
um you know just pushing it pushing it
pushing it and of course in the midst of
that we had our little one
um you know and it was it was a lot of
hard work a lot of sacrifice
um a lot of uh salmon in the can and I
don't want salmon anymore
um you know oatmeal and all that stuff
um even though we were you know steadily
climbing I'm thinking to myself man you
know I can you know I've got folks who
are not making even close to what I'm
making and they're driving amazing cars
and you know and it was hard you know I
wanted and I'm still driving a 14 year
old car you know so
hey I'm gonna get something you know
soon but nonetheless now you're gonna be
driving like no one else because you
drove like no one else yeah yeah so it
was definitely very very tough what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
well two things one is you just can't
quit as tempting as it is on a daily
basis and as much as you want to
especially that's for me minute by
minute yeah it was definitely a moment
by moment so don't quit and then I would
say like it is a sacrificial lifestyle
so with our paying off our student loans
and then our house like that's been
seven and a half years you know most of
our entire marriage we've lived this
very extreme lifestyle and so I would
say it's like enduring the pain there is
a pain point to this type of Lifestyle
it is sacrificial and so if it's not
painful enough you need to probably work
harder at it and that's the surprising
people are adverse to pain but this is
like one of those processes where you
run into the pain and chooks bro you
better buckle up cause she gonna spend
some money
for eight years
you guys are so incredible but hey we've
got the live and give box for you
um it's got a copy of baby steps
millionaire which you already are we've
got The Total Money Makeover which is a
book you can give to somebody else that
you love and you think they would
benefit from it and a year or two
Financial Peace University with every
dollar app you can give away to somebody
else
um go ahead and bring up the little one
yeah yeah and it's banaya is that right
yeah oh look at that handsome guy
Anaya now he's three and a half wow
he's not even gonna know what
he's never gonna understand
best sleepless nights the fights the
frustration he's just gonna think Dad
always drove cars like this and mom
always had three different kinds of
couches in right always y'all have
changed everything congratulations
amazing thank you all right we got
chooks in Virginia and little Benny
banaya paid off 418 thousand dollars in
four years and 10 months making between
three hundred thousand and 550 Grand
they paid off everything including their
house count it down let's hear your debt
free scream
three two one work that free
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show triple
eight eight two five five two two five
listen if you're a new listener
it doesn't take long to realize we have
a bunch of inside baseball we have a
bunch of weird
things that we chant about and weird
things that we do and understand it can
be it can be kind of Bonkers and the
message is so counter-cultural we tell
people who don't care about your credit
score
care people tell people don't care about
your interest rates we can sound nuts
but we also tell you the truth that
millions and millions of people have had
their entire lives changed their whole
family trees changed because they went
through these programs and they've got
on board with just deciding I'm
unplugging from The Matrix and I'm doing
life differently
if you want to know more about what
we're talking about you want to take a
deeper dive into the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button will help you
figure out the best next step for your
financial Journey based on exactly where
you are today that's ramseysolutions.com
click get started all right let's go out
to Amanda down the street here in
Nashville what's up Amanda
hey how are you guys incredible how are
you I'm doing well thank you so what's
up I am going to give you a little bit
of framework and then I'll ask my
question and so my husband and I are
debt free except for a mortgage no car
payments or anything like that and I'm
not going to disclose my income because
I am local but um we are thinking about
moving in with with a family member or
we are definitely moving in with a
family member and we're going to rent
out our house and we don't know if we
should rent it out
a single family and have them cover the
mortgage or if we should attempt to rent
out to a couple of different college
students and have them cover the
mortgage that way because we're close to
a local college and that's something
that we both actually did when we were
in college about a decade ago so it's
just wondering your thoughts on that
so why are you moving in with the family
member
um we
do so we're just going to kind of Park
ourselves and park ourselves for a
little bit and the family member is a
lot closer to our jobs and we know that
we want to move anyway so we're just
going to park and save some money for a
little bit and figure out what we're
going to do with this house and we
figured well it's not being used we
would rent it
why don't you sell your house
uh because we like the idea of having a
rental for now
sounds like you are trying to do
everything all at the same time
and usually that tornado of activity
there's the great role lome is a great
psychologist that talks about when we
get anxious and we get that
we have people in our life that we love
and care about and those relationships
are getting frayed and our bodies get
anxious there's it kicks into this
Obsession towards action we're just
going to do a bunch of stuff all over
the place
we're gonna we're gonna move in with a
family member to save money on expenses
and we're gonna keep a rent house and
we're going to plan for the future but
also we it just gets all over the place
and you end up not going anywhere you
just spin your wheels in the mud and get
real deep
back out a second what are y'all trying
to escape from what are you trying to
move away from what are you trying to
pause you're trying to hit pause on your
life and recalibrate what are you what's
happening here
want to be closer to our jobs so but
you're gonna so you're going to be
landlords an hour away
I mean I guess in theory yes but why not
sell this house and then move closer for
work
well that's the plan we just don't know
what where we're gonna end up just yet
because he's uh we just don't know where
we're gonna end up yet he's what
I honestly don't know what I was gonna
say just then okay all right I can't
escape before he says anything I thought
you're about to say something and you
thought better of it we can answer the
original question of single family
versus college students I don't see a
large difference you know college
students you're going to vet whoever
these people are and so if you get a bad
bad juju you get red flags I'm not
renting to either and so as far as you
know who's gonna pay more could you get
more for it either way I feel like
you're gonna have to charge the same for
rent and I also I do think this though I
think it might be cleaner if you choose
to keep this rental which by the way I
think it's a bad idea I think it makes
little to no sense in your situation
both financially both stress wise in any
shape form or fashion it just doesn't
make sense because then you're going to
run and buy another one you're gonna
have two mortgages outstanding the whole
thing just doesn't doesn't sound right
sounds like you're trying to
um do one thing but keep on another
thing anyway
I think renting a college student is
going to be much cleaner because you may
get a family member in there that
doesn't want to move or doesn't want to
have their rent raised it's just going
to make things a little more complex
whereas if you have some college
students they cycle out every year or
maybe every other year or if you get
some law students that's amazing because
they'll stay three years and they're
great young men and women so
um I I might lean towards the college
students just to keep the whole
relationship business and not have that
extra complexity of having family there
yeah that was my thoughts too and like I
said like we definitely are moving just
to be closer to our job so like if it
ends up not working out like we would
never have two mortgages so if uh like
it doesn't work out after us doing it
for a year or so we would sell the house
at that point so so we're just trying to
figure out what to do in the meantime
sure I
I just I get George we get a lot of
calls about the Allure of I just want to
I want to have rental property and I I
will scroll on Instagram a lot and if I
don't have real estate then I must be
failing and losing and the world's
passing me people get Starry Eyed when
they go well it's passive income and
they're paying my mortgage and both
those things aren't true there's a lot
of assumptions there that worry me and I
feel the anxiety and it's not even my
house when especially what was it 12
months ago all the colleges went home 18
months ago they all went home and so
during the pandemic you couldn't evict
anyone legally so if they didn't pay
they just went sweet I can stay here
squatters rights all right right so I I
yeah
um I love the idea I mean if y'all want
to move closer you have an opportunity
to help out a family member and they can
help you out that's great
um just do one thing at a time as you're
as you're making your way through making
my way down south all right let's go to
Tommy in Evansville what's up Tommy
how are you guys could not be better
literally what's up
yes sir I've got a question for you so I
have two
um basically two parts of debt I've got
student loans and a car payment I have
enough to pay off my car right now my
student loans don't start until
September and I'm wondering if I should
pay off my car right now or wait until
my student loans come due and then pay
it off
what's the amount what's the balances on
those
so I owe 3 000 on my car and then my
student loan debts are 15 000. okay well
I'm paying off the car but for the
reason that it's the smallest balance
and then whatever you have do you have
more money than that sitting around
no I have a thousand in my emergency
phone I'm on baby step number two okay
but you're saying you have another three
you could pay off the car today
yes sir great
let's do that and let's start attacking
the loans right after that
okay but I wouldn't wait for them
because that can could get keep getting
kicked down the road and so I just want
to be free and have it on my terms
regardless of what happens down the line
how much what's your salary taught me
how much you make
about 55 grand a year I'm fresh out of
college so I want to try to attack my
debt early man I want that stuff going
by September by the time there's some
sort of you got to start paying it back
just be done with it
yes sir like literally just live wild
how good would that feel by September
you have no debt all 55 000 minus Uncle
Sam's take stays with you
you start building the emergency fund
how old are you start investing
I'm 22. good grief
Tommy you'll have one
22 and you want to owe anybody anything
and because they're so disorganized you
will get a letters even if you've paid
it off saying your payments begin next
week and you can just smile and be like
no they don't
and I don't know why that just feels
like an Evansville Flex if you ask me it
feels like it would feel good
he's flabbergasted he cannot are you
still there
yeah it's easy for us to say doing it
it's emotional because you worked hard
for this money and you don't know what's
gonna and what a forgiven it and what if
you just paid the money that you took
out and then you moved on with your life
how good would that be George real quick
sometimes when someone says I have
fifteen thousand dollars in student
loans that's six different loans of 900.
split up a whole bunch of baby loans do
you recommend someone and he has a three
thousand dollar car would you take that
three thousand dollar car and put it in
the middle there and pay them up all the
way or just knock the car out and then
start really kind of back at square one
with I go from the smallest balance it
doesn't matter because I feel that
momentum okay and it's the next one
online and the next one in line and it
works every time you do it I love it
versus trying to get fancy with it I
love it well that's an hour in the books
everybody be nice to each other
turn off the news we'll be right back
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth get out of debt do work they love
and create incredible relationships I'm
John deloney joined here by my good
friend George Campbell and we are taking
your calls on everything life money work
relationships your mental health
whatever's going on in your life triple
eight eight two five five two two five
before you go to the phones I want to
get to the question of the day the
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
this isn't listen George this isn't in
the copy the number of times I
email or text somebody at work saying
hey do you know a person here do you
know a person you got a good person here
and then neighborly's like I am all of
those guys and gals yeah I was sick of
trolling my neighborhood Facebook group
searching like who knows a guy who has
good right and they did all the work for
us John 19 service Brands Nationwide you
can find Reliable help from great
locally owned businesses like Mr
Appliance Mr Handyman Mr and dryer vent
Wizard and George's side hustle Mister
how could you possibly be wearing jeans
that small visit neighborly.com today
for help with just about anything for
your home today's question comes from
Lacey in Indiana
she says I have the opportunity to pay
off my student loans if I save for one
year my other option is to buy a house I
know interest rates are high but there's
always the possibility of refinancing
there are also good tax benefits that
come with owning property if I pay off
my student loans though I won't have
enough money for a down payment on a
house realistically for at least two
years so my question is what do you
think is the best long-term option in
terms of financial success buying a
house or paying off my student loans
there's a part of her question I think
solves all of this
she states if I pay off my student loans
I won't have enough money for a down
payment on a house realistically for at
least two years let's just let's just
take off the first part you don't have
enough money for a down payment on a
house ta-da
you can rob Peter to pay Paul but you
don't have enough money you don't have
enough money you don't have enough money
John why are you trying to hurt people's
feelings you're so out of touch I'm just
trying to tell the truth listen here's
what's awesome in two years
realistically as you say you could buy a
house it's pretty awesome
that's really cool in two years you can
buy icing rent rent and pay this off
yeah this is a non-question and there's
a question well I can feel the tone of a
justification here like well John the
tax benefits I'm like what accent ask a
homeowner about all the amazing benefits
they get all the money Savings of owning
a home number one you only get some
benefits if you itemize which almost
nobody does anymore and the whole like
you get you the interest you can write
it off you itemize like so you're
stepping over a dollar to pick up a
quarter I know it's like going to the
bank and be like I'm gonna give you guys
a thousand bucks
we all give me 35 and they'll look at
you and go oh okay that's how it works
you give your lender ten thousand
dollars in interest to get two thousand
from the IRS you're like score got him
and it's a write-off it's not like you
get cash they just deduct yeah anyway
okay yeah I'm gonna play the slow game
Lacey because that's how I found the
best way to build wealth is and uh
Proverbs 13 11 says wealth gained
hastily will dwindle but whoever gathers
little by little will increase it and I
moving slow is so underrated in today's
world because it feels like life's gonna
pass me by John I won't be able to get
that house two years from now but two
years is gonna pass and the question is
do you want to continue to be broke
paying payments while now having a
mortgage or would you rather be free and
step into this thing with wisdom and
patience and margin just solve for
freedom in the
the the mortgage crisis I mean that's
not a crisis but just mortgages
you and I were talking off air you just
explain it what are they trying to do
yeah so I keep people keep sending me
these videos to rile me up and the new
trend now on Tick Tock is the 40-year
mortgage and so let me explain what This
is 40 years it's a 40-year mortgage so
you know about the 15 you love the 30
but let me introduce you to the 40-year
mortgage it reminds me of the office
with uh Dwight and Michael where he says
a 30-year mortgage at Michael's age
essentially means that he's buying a
coffin now if I were to buy my coffin
I'd get one with thicker walls a great
quote
so here's what's actually happening John
the 40-year mortgage is not a thing you
can even go do which I'm really glad I'm
gonna beg to differ because I saw it on
Instagram so there you go George is
wrong so this became a trend and became
a big Google search really what this is
is it's for folks who are already
already had an FHA mortgage and they're
on the brink of foreclosure and so this
is a loan modification that they can now
use in order to avoid a short sale or
foreclosure this is an official Kick the
Can it's for people who are so broke
they're on the verb to bankruptcy and
they said maybe in 10 years your
situation will improve yes and so My
worry is mortgage companies go oh we can
make more money off of this we should
offer it to normal people some guy like
me walks in and is like hey I I want to
only pay this much for my monthly
payment how far can we go and they're
like yeah sure let's do another 10 years
so the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau cfpb as we call it in the biz I
saw that tattoo in your arm yeah I would
I'm a big fan so they actually it's not
a qualified mortgage for them they have
set the rules for this and it's not a
qualified mortgage because this is what
led to the Great Recession in 2007
tonight subprime mortgages people who
couldn't afford houses went well if we
do the 40-year we can barely afford it
that's great and all of a sudden the
banks gave all these people mortgages
who shouldn't have got them and it
created the bubble and it popped so all
that to say John this is a nightmare and
if you didn't believe me can I just
share the numbers with you of course so
this article has a hypothetical loan a
440 000 home with 13 down
so you have a loan for three hundred
eighty three thousand dollars on a
15-year fixed rate about six percent
right now you would have paid about 581
000 total cost so that I mean that sucks
that's still a lot you paid an interest
but when you move to the 30-year
mortgage you will have paid eight
hundred and fifty thousand dollars on
that 383 cost
on the 40-year mortgage on drum roll
please
you would have paid over a million
dollars
for that loan that you took out for
three hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars so the the it almost tripled
this will become a product because the
bank there's too much money to be made
did you I mean look at these numbers
America I'd like to they made almost 700
Grand on a loan for 383. well yeah but
they're going to be 40 years to collect
on it well you're buying a coffin they
don't seem too concerned they're playing
the long game John listen we have to get
to a place where we are no longer
fighting scratching for a wiggle room
well and we're scratching for lower
payments John because we need
flexibility because inflation and what
if I want more to my life than wiggle
room and flexibility and okay I can
afford that payment and that payment and
that payment when I look at my total
take home for the month
I I wanna unhook from The Matrix
completely I want to solve for Freedom
here I want to get off this whole ride I
get off the whole ride
I don't think most people just walking
through the day realize this weight
that's on their chest and they think
that this is as deep as I can breathe
and they think this is as good as my
sleep is ever going to be and they think
that just a couple more beers and this
is as good as it gets and there's just
so much more to life and this just feels
like
someone who's can't breathe and it's
like I'll give you a little sip of air
through a straw every day for 10 more
years and we're gonna high-five you and
call that life I don't want that life
thank you to a great life is not lower
payments it's no payments no payments
that's true margin that's three Freedom
choose Freedom every single time stop
selling your soul for wiggle room choose
Freedom this is the Ramsey Show we'll be
right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five it's triple eight eight two five
five two two five I'm John deloney
joined here by George Campbell taking
your calls on money in relationships
mental health life whatever you got
we're here let's go out to Courtney in
Owensboro Kentucky what's up Courtney
how we doing
thank you so much for taking my call of
course what's happening
um my husband and I just started on baby
step two and he just recently accepted
that position at another job and they
will be giving him a work vehicle so my
question is should we sell his personal
vehicles that he was using for his
previous job as a work car and put it
down on the debt
what's that car worth
about three thousand okay you don't owe
anything on it
no we only owe on my car how much is
left on that
sixteen thousand and that's all of your
debt
I accept the house we have 75 000 on a
house cool what's your household income
now this new job
54 000.
okay and he can use this company vehicle
as long as he wants as much as he wants
yeah start giving them gas card and
everything so wow it's a sweet deal
yeah I mean if you can if you can sell
that thing for three or more private
party sale clean it up nice take some
good photos and use that towards the
death that'll speed up this process by
at least a few months right
yes yes it would hey Courtney can I plot
twist
okay
what if you sold your car and you drove
the three thousand dollar car boom what
if tonight at dinner you slid your keys
across the table all dramatic like you
got some real real dramatic music and
you just said honey I'm all in too
you're gonna drive this company car
around I'm gonna drive your embarrassing
car and I'll sell the 16 000 car will be
debt free uh this weekend
my husband actually brought that up to
me today but
it's a my choice I'm afraid to get rid
of it it's emotional for you
what kind of car is it
it's a Toyota Camry a 2019 but
that's a sweet sweet whip great car it's
a great car what's the payment on it
okay so what if we sold it and you took
that 300 and you just started putting in
the bank plus more because you don't
have any payments now
how quickly could you save up and pay
for that thing with cash later on down
the road
a few years I'm sure it shouldn't take
too long though I wouldn't think and
you've depreciated that three thousand
dollar car out so if you sell it this
weekend for three thousand or a couple
of years it's you're probably gonna get
three thousand for it right
right people are happy to find a three
thousand dollar car they say it doesn't
exist when they call our show so I know
people would buy in a heartbeat
I I love the idea of you putting that on
the table and maybe it's no great
coincidence that I mentioned it and your
husband and I bet it took it did it take
a long time to mention it too did he do
it all roundabout kind of way
I'm sorry
did he circle the wagons was he kind of
him haunt around it or did he just come
out and say Hey what if you sold your
car
he just brought it up today as an idea
he didn't really beat around the bush
about it too much we're just really
trying to we're sick and tired of their
debt and we're trying to get out of it
as fast as we can so I love it that
that's honestly
um what I would do like if I'm in that
situation my wife had a three thousand
dollar car and I had a 16 000 car and
that was all of our debt I would try to
sell that as quickly as possible and get
out of it so it's a good move either way
I mean mathematically financially you're
okay but again you said to us that
you're sick and tired of debt and it's
probably another what six to 12 months
before we can get rid of this car loan
even after selling the other car yeah
that's right and so I love the idea of
you guys being debt free today yep all
right let's go to Andrew in Fort Myers
what's up Andrew
how's it going guys a pleasure to talk
to you you too man we're partying what's
up
all right so in 2022 I paused my
retirement contributions in order to
save cash for my wedding which is
actually less than three weeks away now
um and I'm trying to determine my next
step so should I remain paused in my
retirement investings in order to save
up for a down payment in two to three
years or should um I go back to
investing in retirement after we get
married how old are you two
I'm 24 in my soon-to-be wife is 20. cool
and what will your household income be
you think once you guys are married
it should be a little over 90.
okay
so there's a few ways to to skin this
cat some people go scorched Earth and
they go two years we're going to keep
retirement paused and just save up that
down payment some people split the
difference and get you know the employer
match the rest goes to the down payment
and some people just do 15 anything left
over they do that the down payment but
again that would take longer right and
so it really depends on your the goal
that you guys set together for when we
need this house now 20 and 24 you got so
much time it blows my mind but also at
20 and 24 everyone around you is like
why are you throwing money away on rent
you guys need to be in a house you're
doing great and so number one you got to
turn those voices off and do what's
right for you guys and I love the idea
of you guys getting started on investing
while saving up and if you need to make
up the difference with extra jobs side
hustles whatever you need to do Now's
the Time to do it yeah and George
there's something about
um Dave calls it flexing the muscle
there's something about practice like
even if it's a small amount and we're
going to mostly save up for our down
payment
I like the idea of just seeing that on
your budget month after month year after
year we give and we put it in mind to
retirement even 25 bucks a month we put
money into retirement it's just how we
do it when my wife and I who works here
at Ramsey when we save for our down
payment we both did 15 into our Roth
401k here at Ramsey we put that on
autopilot and we just pretended like
that money never existed and we learned
to live on less and then we went how do
we hit this down payment goal and that
will pay dividends in the future for
sure I
we went bananas right we stopped
everything but we scorched Earth and we
gotta got it got that down payment
pretty quick before we rolled out so
it's 6.5 another but what I don't want
for Andrew or for any of us is to look
up and suddenly you've put pause on
retirement for two years five years
seven years if it's more than two years
you gotta get started investing beyond
that because what's gonna happen they're
gonna save up for down payment and then
she's gonna wind up pregnant and then
they're gonna so it's always gonna be a
reason to not be investing right and
just keep bouncing and bouncing and
bouncing around yeah
um George when you look at young couples
getting married
um
they're trying to save for a wedding
they're thinking they've got these
dreams of a house they thinking about
having kids where do they start
well hopefully they start debt free that
is the best way you can start off any
marriage but having that Vision together
of what our life looks like most couples
don't take the time to do that they take
more time to plan the honeymoon than
they do to plan their finances and their
money or that once that one party that
one night yes goodness gracious the
amount of time and money we put into
weddings if we put that into our
retirement goals we would be all be
multi-millionaires because effort and
intentionality went into it so it takes
getting on the same plan the same vision
the same goals the same communication
with money but having a goal right in
front of you what is a one-year goal and
then what's the 10-year one that's
further out that kept me and my wife
real driven on the money plan but if
you've got debt you already have your
priority right there for you we got it
that's nice we're getting rid of this
debt as soon as the wedding's over and
you and your wife did a great job of
setting that goal and then reverse
engineering those behaviors all the way
to the present and just
I don't know you're an inspiration to me
because I like to do it all at the same
time and just get on and I just see you
over there with a chisel and a hammer
just dinking away at it and it and
here's the thing I get to the finish
line and I'm exhausted and I can't
breathe and you just walk on by and
you're like hey I made it I'll see you
later and just keep walking and I'm like
yeah we we were extra weird because we
started off our marriage in such an
amazing place because my wife has
already worked here for years by that
point uh and so when you start your
marriage off that way we just
pre-decided we're going to get a real
modest home and pay it off real fast and
what would our life be like and I didn't
know yeah those two cult members getting
married so y'all already very different
but I drove that you know that old Honda
Civic that was all beat up the Bumper's
hanging off Dave's making fun of me and
I said I'm not upgrading that car until
I pay off the house right
and I upgraded after the house I did
what I said I was going to do John but I
always need to dangle that carrot
otherwise I think we get kind of lazy as
humans if that carrot isn't in front of
us oh in a good way
it's not I deserved it that I think
that's the wrong mentality when you get
married you start to go well we deserve
we work hard we're made couples I think
use it it's a picture of marriage like
when you're married you all of a sudden
just get a house that's fully furnished
and all these cool things and like all
the cool containers in the in the pantry
and two dogs that are some doodle
derivative or oh yeah like yours but
um the the mutants that you have but we
just see it we think marriage we see
this picture and it's supposed to fill
itself out and we don't take the time to
realize no there's a bunch of steps
along the way yeah do it slow do it the
right way do it with cash this is the
Ramsey Show triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
cschm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go out to Stephen in Staples
Minnesota what's up Stephen
Hi how are you outstanding how are you
oh doing well very good what's up so
um my wife and I recently found your
program and decided we want to get out
of debt we want baby step two welcome to
the game my man
I ended up in kind of an odd spot
um we quit making payments on student
loans since there wasn't interested in
forbearance and started saving that
money for a down payment on a home
up and now we're looking to buy a home
and sell the home that we currently have
and pay off debt and we're trying to one
figure out what order to do it in and
how to how we should uh utilize their
assets
so in your mind does this debt just not
exist we're like we're just going to
move on with our life we're just gonna
let us sit over there
no uh we actually saved up enough to pay
it off the lump sum we just made the
payments to ourselves
whoa and you have that in cash today
yeah and then I've got a balloon payment
on a piece of property for about 30 000
coming up do you have that in dash too
yes
how much cash do you have bro about 140.
so 140 would wipe out your student loans
and the balloon payment and then you're
done you're completely debt free but
you're back to square one when it comes
to a future home
correct other than equity in your home
how much do you have in your home
between 250 and 300
would that work as a down payment if you
sold
well that's where I'm getting nervous
because we my wife actually found a
house she liked and we have a purchase
agreement oh my gosh Stephen what are
you doing
so this would be
20 a little over 20 percent down on the
home for a down payment
and then we could sell what we have and
use the equity to pay off debt please
don't do that or please don't do that
Stephen
think think about it we were told to get
a bridge loan and don't don't care who
are you getting advice from currently
uh our Banker ah there it is yes what
are banks in the business of doing
giving out loans
their product is money and they sell
them to people like you and you're like
oh okay you have a hundred and forty
thousand dollars in the bank and
somebody's convinced you to borrow more
money just think about that for a second
the other thing after very little
learning about your program
um I was wondering if it'd be wise to
liquidate some assets what do you got a
couple Vehicles yes or a boat I would
sell all the toys you're not using
do you need them well I like use them
I need the strong word how many cars do
you have
I think seven total oh my gosh
Stephen what do you do for a living
please tell me you're on a tiny used car
dealership
no I'm uh technically uh I just work for
cash on the side and we'll do whatever
my wife tells me I was about to say do
you sell drugs and I think that's what
you just answered like what do you do no
I I don't say I don't bear it okay okay
what is your household what's your
what's your wife to
I'm not sure she's a ob gyn okay awesome
I I mean I think he's in the middle of
the night a lot yeah I think the title
of her job would clarify what she does
but that's cool so listen
um
let's let's re-look at this a whole
other way okay
I want you to take a huge deep breath
and hold it as as deep as you can I want
you to hold it for a count of two okay
take a big deep breath
yeah
got it one
two now exhale it and then I want you to
consciously drop your shoulders pull
your elbows down and drop your shoulders
for a second
okay
now yeah
I want you to imagine
you don't owe anybody anything
and you're in your same house and your
quarter of a million dollars in equity
up on it
you don't owe anybody anything
you're somehow scraping by with four
cars instead of seven
if you only use the boat once a year
you've considered selling it and you can
rent one on the once a year you actually
go out on it or maybe you you're like my
father-in-law who's on the boat more
than he's on dry land and so maybe
that's just your thing
the goal here you're trying you you're
so over complicated all of this stuff
with the math and the somersaults and
the bridge loans and what about this is
and we're going to use this Equity we're
gonna move it over here but I'm gonna
take this money and sell it over here
and you're just solving for chaos and
more chaos and more chaos and the whole
purpose of this program is to solve for
peace
is to help people live peaceful
non-chaotic lives your wife lives a
chaotic life you as the person taking
care of that home
life is stressful enough man and to just
throw just start lighting fires just to
watch things burn just doesn't make a
lot of sense in this day and age does
that you get what I'm trying to say
yep that's that's the approach so that's
why George will tell you Dave will tell
you well I'll tell you this is way more
a psychology than it is mathematics
because somebody can make a case I guess
go ahead
that makes a lot of sense
um and what I'm trying to understand so
removing to this house she took a new
job in a new town okay and trying to
keep everything or trying to calm
everything down
to get the house and and not have PMI
and how we can do all this how much is
this house you just bought it's over a
million dollars isn't it
ah 470.
but if you have 250
000 in equity you said you're only gonna
have 20 down
yep but we won't be able to get the
equity out until after we've sold
so we'll have two mortgages for a couple
months
with the balloon payment coming up and
the student loans on the horizon
yeah and maintenance and insurance on 17
toys I'm stressed out just thinking
about it I know I literally have
hemorrhoids right now just talking to
you so
I'm a man of Simplicity yeah so I'm just
like what gets me to the most simplest
life the fastest and that is to just
Napalm this thing go what can I sell
that I really won't miss that I can
always get later when I've cleared this
mess up
and that means I'm paying off the
student loans I'm getting rid of the
balloon payment with cash that leaves me
what six grand gonna restock my
emergency fund and if I want to do that
faster I'm selling a bunch of toys to do
it
then I'm gonna sell the house and
whatever Equity we have will dictate the
kind of house we get
that's simple to me I can breathe
thinking about that
and you might only be able to put down
18 or 14 and you don't have that PMI
thing and that's just gonna be a sucker
tax that you pay because you did all
these things out of order
but I would love to see this I would
love to see you and your wife sit down
and just maybe for the first time ever
dream for a second about the life you'll
want to create it's real easy to go to
med school and then you're like well
I'll stay at home and that ball just
gets rolling down the hill and all of a
sudden your life is just a series of
trying to catch up with whatever
decisions being made in real time
and as the old saying goes if you don't
know where you're going You're sure
you're sure to end up there you're just
going to find yourself in some place in
some town with a new job and a new house
and you're gonna have two mortgages you
can have 17 cars and a pony and a Frog
like all these things right
I'd love to see you in your wife sit
down and say hey what kind of world do
we want to build for ourselves now that
we're moving now that you're taking a
new job what if we pause for a second
and just said okay what kind of planet
do we want to inhabit
and does that planet have seven cars
does it have two bass boats and does it
have all these jet skis and all all the
stuff see what I'm saying
yes absolutely does that sound does that
sound appealing or do we just sound like
too boring old men oh no and absolutely
it sounds appealing in that I think that
you're entirely right then
getting going too fast and allowing the
stress the cloud Vision in this
situation is what's causing the issues
now
make no mistake the next few months are
going to be stressful regardless if you
go cleaning up your cars and taking
pictures of them and having people
coming to look at them it's going to be
anxious paying off your student loans
today imagine this for the next few
months whenever they say Biden has a new
announcement about student loans you can
just change the channel because you
don't care because you don't owe anybody
anything who cares I took the loans out
I can pay him back I'm not gonna wait
for the government to pay something back
that I sign my name too I'm just gonna
pay them off
solve for Freedom my man this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
tax day and about one-fourth of you wait
to file your taxes until the last couple
of weeks so if you planned on doing it
tonight or tomorrow because you live for
the thrill of cutting it close to the
deadline it sounds like you John in
other parts of your life dude I I like
to get my taxes done like January 2nd
man that's why I said in other parts
always hassle yeah every other part of
my life I'm like flying hot that's right
it's time to get you your butts in gear
let's get this thing done more people
have ended up with a tax bill this year
so it's more important than ever to file
on time if you owe taxes but you don't
file on time you could be penalized
meaning you pay Uncle Sam fees and
interest on top of your taxes I've never
met anybody that said man I think I'm
just gonna pay more so don't don't put
off your taxes anymore you don't have
time for that and with the right tax
software you can still file quickly and
easily for tax software that's on your
side check out Ramsay smart tax it's a
low-cost option that doesn't hit you
with any surprise fees or offers to put
you in debt get your taxes done now so
you can stop worrying about it go to
ramsaysolutions.com
smart tax and save up to seventy percent
when you switch from other software
that's
ramseysolutions.com slash smart tax John
that reminds me I I made this post the
other day and it got picked up on social
by a crypto newsletter that has a
quarter million subscribers and a buddy
of mine sent it to me he's like dude
you're featured in this and I thought
it'd be fun to read this social post
together let's do it so I'm gonna play
the part of the IRS and you are the
American taxpayer you're excellent good
hey John you owe us money it's called
taxes
well how how much oh you'll figure it
out
uh okay so I just pay you what I think
is right oh no we we know exactly how
much but you have to guess oh well what
if I'm wrong ah fees maybe jail we'll
see
end scene and scene so that's how it
feels for most people and it can be
really confusing and it's why we
recommend get the stuff done early so
that you know if you're gonna owe or not
you have time to save if you know if
you're gonna get a refund and if you
know I gotta work with a tax Pro because
it's super complicated and uh of course
our Ramsay smart tag software makes it
easy enough that even John deloney can
do it himself to do yeah a couple years
I use this stuff is all it was great
um it reminds me of like when your mom
or dad calls you in and says do you have
something to tell me
it's a trap just tell me what you know
that I did like
um I feel like that's entrapment does
that count it's not really what a trap
is but it's fun to say it out loud
that's what kids say it's like
gaslighting we just started using it as
a blanket term for everything and
everyone's a narcissist you're
gaslighting me then you're a narcissist
no I just think you're dumb all right
let's go to Zach in Harrisburg what's up
Zach
uh not much um I have a question
um I was just informed the other day at
work that the plant will be closing down
I'm a machinist by trade oh man my face
yeah I know
um my base salary is around 56 000 uh
last year I made 70 something because of
all the overtime I work
um uh uh long and short of it I'm about
nine thousand dollars in debt between a
personal loan and two credit cards
um
I'm on baby step two I have a thousand
dollars in savings right now
um I also need a new roof on my house
the quote that I got was 12 to 15. I can
do it myself for around five which I
will
um but my question is do I stop
doing the uh snowball and do I stack
money and get ready for the rainy day
that I know that's coming in a year from
now or do I continue to pay the nine
thousand dollars in debt down and cash
flow the roof and then save as much as
possible and get a part-time job to get
me through and
have a nest egg for whenever the plant
closes down and they start layoffs
what's keeping you at the plant it's
like if Dave came in and said hey uh in
one year we're closing up Ramsey
Solutions
I would immediately start looking for
the next place I was going to go so what
what do they have you how they have you
tied in there for the next year
the severance package
so you have to stay for the next 12
months tell me about it
uh so uh basically the severance
packages
um it's a year and a half it's one and a
half weeks for every year of service
I've been there will be six years so
I'll look at nine weeks
um pay
and I'm not going to be able to find a
job around here making the same amount
of money that I am now so for right now
I'm cool with making you know what I
make hourly and then
I only work weekends so I work 36 hours
a week I bring home around fifteen
hundred dollars every two weeks and
all during the week I have the potential
to get a part-time job
but hold on one second what you're
do you come from money are you the first
person in your family to make 70 grand a
year
I don't know you don't know I don't know
um both of my parents um my adopted
parents had passed away okay
um so
so the way the way you're talking about
your your predicament and your situation
um
it sounds a lot like me to be honest
with you and my I got great parents we
just didn't talk about money very much
money was really a source of stress and
so I didn't know
and when when you don't know
um you either like George talks about a
lot on on the George Campbell show that
you either get into all these crazy
traps like buying crypto and all kind of
weird stuff or you just get in this
strange survival I'm just gonna take one
more step and one more step and one more
step
and so yeah I want you to recognize the
scope of what's happened you're probably
gonna have to move
you're probably going to no longer have
just weekends
and you may have a six day a week job or
a five day a week job like your life is
I'm completely fine with that cool so
what I would what I would suggest is
begin to imagine or to not just not not
only just imagine dig in
with both hands and feet and you are not
a guy that's that's scared of hard work
that's who that's that's in your DNA
that's who you are
where do you want to move where do you
want to live what kind of Life do you
want to have because the change has been
thrust upon you and what I'm guessing if
you move to the right town and the right
community in the right work situation
you're going to be able to make this
this magical nine weeks they dangle this
stuff over but if you actually just do
the math on it it's often less than a
signing bonus you're going to get to go
work in another community
and you'll be able to do it earlier get
your life set up and go ahead and move
on with your life
okay
um I also have a mortgage okay
so I'm sorry are you just gonna wait
till the year is up and be like oh man I
got a mortgage are you going to sell
your house because they've given you a
year notice
yeah
so here's there there is a storm coming
but it's not tomorrow so if the news
today there's a storm coming 12 months
from now I'm not going to pretend like a
storm's coming tomorrow what I am going
to do is start preparing so that when
that storm comes I'm ready and so
looking at these numbers you got 9k in
debt you said you need 5K to cash flow
the roof and do it yourself
and we need to fully fund the emergency
fund that would be my A1 over the next
12 months
I have 4 200 in the Employee Stock
purchasing program also okay so I'm
going to use that and cash it out as
soon as I can when you're fully vested
and that's going to help this process
but looking at the numbers you need
about 25 30k in the next 12 months so
you divide that out we need 2 500 bucks
a month to make this plan work and
whatever side jobs I need to do to get
that kind of margin whatever I need to
do lower my expenses that's my plan
so we're paying off the 9k we're going
to cash flow the roof we're going to get
the emergency fund and in 12 months when
they give you that severance plan you go
all right I'm going to sell the house
I'm going to move and I already have a
job lined up or
you call a buddy in whatever Community
you want to think about moving to or
whatever job you want to do and you
start having those conversations in the
evening and on the weekends
um hey do you guys need somebody here's
what it's going to take financially
here's what's going to cost or maybe you
want to get out of being a machinist all
together you want to do something else
you got a year to get trained up and and
certified to do something else and if
you find the right job in four months
then sell your house and throw up the
Deuces and walk out right brush your
shoulders off and move
they're closing the factory on you see
what I'm saying okay yeah the severance
plan isn't sweet enough that it's worth
pausing your life if they said we're
going to give you fifty thousand dollars
if you stay well then okay then I'll
stay for a year
but man right now you're gonna put a lot
of equity into that house bill put a new
roof on it and then turn around and sell
it because you're gonna have to leave
your community because you're not going
to take that much you're not going to
take a half of a pay cut right
yeah
do you do you are your days in
Harrisburg numbered I mean do you
believe that
oh yeah definitely I mean within it's
the point is going to close but there
are no machinist jobs in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania other than this plant
yeah there are plenty of plants around
here that's what I'm saying I don't have
to sell the house I can go elsewhere
work in another Factory that's within 10
miles let's start doing the homework
let's get on that one excellent
excellent my man this is the Ramsey Show
we'll be right back just after this
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where we help
people build wealth do work they love
pay off their debts and create
incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined here by my good friend
George Campbell and we're taking your
calls on money life mental health
relationships whatever you got going on
we're here for your work whatever it is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five it's triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go out to
Gabrielle in Spokane Washington what's
up Gabrielle
hi
what's up
so I work for myself that's nice of you
I haven't thank you very much
um but I haven't filed my taxes in
several years and I just don't really
know where to start that is not nice of
you
why haven't you filed
I have struggled a lot with mental
health and physical health and last year
was kind of the first
first start of my life where I could
kind of Take Back Control where I got
things sorted out I started taking big
steps in you know really taking back
control and not just letting life go by
um so but you've run the business the
whole time and it's made money
and I was getting fully booked but then
back in 2020 covet hit and I ended up
having to move from Hawaii back to
um the Pacific Northwest to be close to
family and then I kind of had to restart
all over again so I'm barely making ends
meet right now but it is progressing I
am gaining more clients
so how much it's going in a good
direction how much do you owe
so on that I am not even sure
um because the during covid and you know
maybe one or two years after
I wasn't even making up to ten thousand
dollars and so all of the tax advice
that I've ever heard in my life was if
you don't make up to ten thousand
dollars and you don't even have to file
so for me it was just I don't know where
you heard that advice you could have
done a Google search in that time and
figured it out
yeah okay well it sounds like you're
done bearing your head in the sand you
want to deal with this
completely sorry forgot to say I'm proud
of you that's that's a boldness good for
you that's amazing okay and I say I'm
proud of you everyone should be paying
their taxes and never and there's people
listening rolling their eyes and blah
blah you've been struggling for a few
years and you're you're saying I'm ready
to get this broom go clean up this mess
that's that's in my past and good for
you good for you thank you so there
there may be a boogie man under the bed
and it's going to be penalties and taxes
and so we have to get a very clear
picture of what we owe
including those penalties
right and that will at least go okay it
wasn't a boogeyman it's five thousand
dollars great how much pet sitting do I
need to do what kind of jobs do I need
to take to get the IRS off my back
because I promise you they haven't
forgotten
right and right now the hard part for
you is just going hey IRS I'm here sorry
it's been a while I'm ready to pay what
I owe what do I owe do you have your
1099s from the last two years
I don't
okay no I'm pretty much as unprepared as
I as I could possibly be what do you
have do you have bank statements that
show the money coming in or an email
from Rover saying here's your annual
I do yes and I'm in the process of
trying to get I figured I'd start from
the most current back because that's the
most clear in my head but I I have
started to work my way backwards
throughout the years to get as many you
know bank statements receipts um any
sort of actual documentation that I can
I think the most important documentation
is to go back to the to the companies
that you worked for and ask for 1099s
and I would imagine that a place like
Rover will give you a log Insight that
you'll go in and put your stuff in and
it will just tell you we paid you this
much in 2019 we paid you this much 2020
we paid you this much in 2021 whatever
did you do this on your own as well
through you know venmo or just payment
services PayPal I did okay so they will
have records of well of all of the
transactions that came through
right okay so I would gather all of that
that you can to be as accurate as you
can
and even cash if there was cash payments
that you know happened if you have
statements write all that down and the
next thing I would do because this is
scary on your own is get with a tax Pro
and we have a network of amazing tax
pros at ramseysolutions.com tax and they
can walk you through this and they're
going to help you get through this mess
to where you're now current on your
taxes and you're going to do quarterly
estimated payments from now on they're
going to teach you about that and you're
gonna have confidence moving forward
instead of kind of bearing this under
the rug
yeah that sounds great this is not the
end of the world no you're not you're
not close you're not even close to the
end of the world do you have any money
right
I
I actually just got my 500 saved up
awesome on my baby steps because I do
have an older vehicle but I drive you
know one to 200 miles a day pretty much
I'm in a pretty large radius so and my
my car is you know up to in the mid 200
000 mile range so I know I have some
stuff coming
um what does your life look like in
three years
is this your Forever job
so I actually have have thought quite a
bit about this and I would like to have
an additional whether that's an
independent contractor or an employee to
help me run this business but I also
started baking and selling dog treats
which are doing pretty well so I know I
want to stay kind of in this realm um I
I am an LLC like I'm a bonded licensed
insured and everything like that so
um I do want to kind of take this and
run with this
um so I'm gonna I'm gonna send you a
copy I want you to stay on the line here
and AJ's going to get it for you I'm
going to send you a copy of our friend
Ken Coleman's book The Proximity
principle you know what you want to do
you know what you like to do now you're
having questions about scaling this up
and how do I get more customers and what
does it look like in this area and he
wrote an entire book about how to make
those connections with other people in
other Industries and how to take this
thing from an idea which right now quite
honestly when you look at your bottom
line this year it's it's it's it's a
glorified idea right you're making a
little bit of money you're scratching a
clawing
but you're gonna need other people in
your corner to take this to the next
level and so Ken's book will help you
that um yeah call it call get online and
get go get a Ramsay trusted and um
what's the website there George
ramseysolutions.com tax slash tickets
and then somebody in your community call
them and just say be a hundred percent
honest say I'm in a mess I'm in a mess
and um I need some help and they'll
they'll give you a step I promise you
they've seen worse oh so that's the good
news yes they've seen multi-millionaires
who haven't paid their taxes in decades
and they come and say whoops whoops
right I'll tell you this much John as a
dog dad I spend a lot of money on Doggy
Daycare and people to come walk the dogs
during lunch you can make great money of
trauma and uh being disillusioned and um
having a a a not a great grasp on
reality today I'm celebrating a pretty
big milestone one year to ago today my
book own your past change your future
hit the shelves and the reason this
anniversary is so special is because of
you talking about thousands of you who
picked up a copy and decided to take
your first step towards healing it's not
too late for you George that first step
towards wellness it's my way this book
is my way of sitting 101 with you and
talking about life the struggles the
good stuff the not so good stuff and the
hope for your future so for today only
with every purchase of own your past
change your future in the Ramsey store
I'm throwing in the audiobook and ebook
versions and my bricks in your backpack
talk go to ramsesolutions.com
store that's ramsesolutions.com store
[Music]
thank you
it's National financial literacy month
and we are taking today to celebrate
financial literacy is important stuff
and we don't spend enough time talking
about it with our kids in the years that
we've been teaching the baby steps I
can't tell you how many times we've
heard someone say I wish this stuff was
in high school I wish I'd learned this
stuff earlier and that's how we created
our foundations and personal finance
curriculum it's now been taught in over
45 percent of the high schools in the
United States it's incredible
but you know who really makes this
possible
teachers
if we learned anything over the last
three or four years is the country stops
without teachers
today we have one of our rock star
Foundation teachers Laura from White
House Texas it's near Tyler Texas there
on the border on the show with us today
let's go to Laura hey Laura what's
happening
hi it's a great day to be teaching
personal finance right you're so
incredible you sound like a like a
teacher it's so amazing I feel calmer
already
all right so what school where do you
teach Laura
I teach at White House High School and
how many teachers how many students are
there
there are about 1400 now in our high
school wow how long have you been a
teacher
this is my 17th year
that's like 2 000 years in teacher lives
17 years incredible what Grace do you
teach yeah
I teach all grades and and business
classes but most of my personal finance
classes are Juniors and seniors all
right so do you have some success
stories
um from current or previous students
about how this curriculum impacted their
lives
of course yes I love running into former
students around town
um for example I was in a clothing store
one day and I noticed the cashier was
one of my former students and before we
could even say a greeting she told me
she has 3 000 in her savings account and
she's going to Tyler Junior College and
she's paying cash and oh my gosh you
know just exploded with excitement to
tell me and share with me how she's
managing her money well and doing what
she heard in the class normally if
you're not a part of a weird group like
this Ramsay way group just meeting
somebody in a grocery store and they
yell at you how much money they have in
their checking account it's pretty weird
except here right it's completely normal
with this group
um so yeah how does that feel
oh it's wonderful it inspires me to keep
teaching and motivates me you know the
students are looking at me and and
they're engaged and they're listening
because they know this is relevant and
half of my students are working right
now so they're applying this now and
eager to get started and
um when I you know they listen and when
I run into a student like that or a
student in the movie theater the other
day I was walking to my movie and a
student I heard footsteps coming behind
me and I turned around and there's a
student a former student and she said
hey I paid I just bought my first car
and I paid cash for it and the next
thing I know there's a phone screen with
a little red car you know that she's
showing me and we just had to hug and
jump and you know celebrate and I have
no idea what movie I saw but wow know
that makes me want to how did you get
involved with foundation's curriculum
how did you get involved with this
Ramsey stuff
well you know I've been a fan for a long
time years and years ago my husband went
to Dallas to a conference and came home
saying we need to do this and we got on
board
um getting our money organized and when
the opportunity to teach personal
finance and came to our high school I
said you know can I use the Ramsey
curriculum and they said absolutely so
I've got a supportive Administration
um that we've used the foundations and
I'm so happy to have it it is great
curriculum I don't know that I've heard
the sentence I have a supportive
Administration from a teacher in a long
time that's incredible
incredible you know I work for a great
district and they see the importance of
financial literacy and the state of
Texas did not require
a financial literacy course and be
offered in the high school until 2016.
and we were doing it long before that
how long have you been teaching
foundations
10 years wow
you're incredible you're a hero and
there I can't think of anything more
fulfilling and more joy than to meet
those kids and go I got to be a part of
their financial success their Financial
Freedom and see them graduate debt free
yeah what are the most common questions
you get about foundations
well the the students get
guided about
it they see the compound interest
compound interest and you know at the
beginning of the year we talked about
savings and part of savings emergency
funds for large purchases and Building
Wealth well you know we give that
demonstration of compound interest and
and they're ready to go they're like I
got thirty dollars where do I put it you
know and I say calm down we got let's
build that emergency fund first we're
going to go in order here of things we
need to do as a high school student
and um
you know they're they are patient for a
minute and then they after class they
come up to me and say so where exactly
do I go where do you go what's the
what's the address the name of the place
and how much do I do do I give them and
um
so that's that's the biggest thing is
um how do I become a millionaire
and build my wealth no high school
teacher ever told me to calm down so
Laura so I don't really know what
hearing those words is like but
um hey do you know the current
legislation in Texas regarding personal
finance required course you said is 2016
so it's required every high school
student has to have it to graduate well
it yes it's required that a half credit
course is offered no one has to take it
but at least it's on the course and they
have to offer it that's a start it's not
required well I'm sure you're pushing
all the kids going you should sign up
for my class because it's freaking
awesome
you know I don't have to push
it that's amazing amazing year well
George and I are both in the curriculum
and we can say that it's good
but it's not that good that means you're
a great great teacher
well you guys are awesome and the
curriculum is great and you know what
you I get emails asking for feedback and
your team listens and they apply what
teachers are giving in feedback and it's
a great curriculum to start with and
it's even getting better
week by week well I want to tell you I
come from a
um a house full of teachers a family
full of teachers and so on behalf of
teachers everywhere who get up at five
o'clock in the morning to answer parent
emails and then get to get to the school
at 6 30 or 7 and they don't stop grading
papers and answering emails till 7 pm at
night and they do this day in and day
out for months after month after month
after month after month thank you so
much for loving these kids inside of
that classroom loving them outside of
the classroom teaching foundations for a
decade means you love their grandkids
and you haven't even met them yet that's
just who you are and so on behalf of all
of us who aren't in the classroom day to
day out thank you so so so so much for
your heart and your compassion and for
teaching these students the financial
literacy for any teachers listening
don't forget to enter the Ramsey teacher
appreciation giveaway sponsored by the
Army National Guard one teacher will win
a five thousand dollar vacation and two
more teachers will each win a three
thousand dollar vacation
teachers you need vacations we're going
to give them to you go to
ramsesolutions.com
teacher to enter that's
teacher to enter George you have a
teacher that made a huge impact on your
life absolutely Dr laflam senior year
high school changed my life English
he inspired me creative writing
songwriting got me into music and got me
just went hey you've got something here
and I I love it I want to help you hone
this craft and it was one of the first
people who believed in me wow and I'll
never forget him that's I my list of
teachers that were important to me are
so long
um gosh I consider all day and then I'll
get all emotional and weepy I know I
just feel like I just it's warm-hearted
just listening to Laura it's amazing
amazing teachers thank you for what you
do this is the Ramsey Show we'll be
right back
[Music]
foreign
show and I'm looking across the lobby to
the debt free stage and I see Mark and
Jenny from North Carolina how's it going
wonderful great so good to see you so
you're on the debt free stage so I'm
assuming you're here to do your debt
free scream how much have you paid off
seven hundred and three thousand and
seventy two dollars
okay
that works for me wow all right it's
rare that I'm speechless and you got me
um how long did it take you 23 months
okay the story continues all right he's
got Kanye money okay what was your range
of income during this time
um we started at 250 and we uh through
the process increased it to 300. wow wow
okay so there's a story here what what
got sold
we did sell some properties nice we had
quite a few rentals all with mortgages
associated with them and the increase in
um
income was mainly due to Mark's increase
in retirement benefits through the
military as well as we were able to
raise some rents on some others
what do I do for a living
um I own a party rental business and I'm
a practicing attorney awesome very cool
so that's a great combo right there no
party rental attorney I'm still
practicing though so what kind of debt
was the 703
it was a lot of rentals about 163 000 in
mortgage on rentals about 220 000 in
business debt
um the acquisition of his business and
just some various lines of credit and
then we had um
I still had some student loans I've been
out of school for 20 years wow law
school loans can hang on you for a while
so are you are you operating this party
business debt free I am now wow that's
incredible so how much of the rental how
much of this payoff was the rental
properties versus you guys using the
cash flow so we sold about 250 000 well
that was the net proceeds that we
applied to the debt and then the rest of
it we were just killing it 10 15 20 000
a month going toward debt wow okay what
happened 23 months ago I got to hear the
story so we're a blended family of six
we have four adult kids ranging in age
from 28 to 21.
and I was really upset about the way
these kids were handling their money
because they just didn't know how to do
it like we were with the seven hundred
thousand dollars in debt so
um I was really looking for some content
on how to talk to them about money
management and um
and that's where I learned about the
Ramsey Show
so I mean that's still there's learning
and then there's going all right we're
going to clean up 700 Grand in 23 months
so the interesting thing was um I
started reading the books listening to
the podcast
um enrolled in FPU and I realized how
many mistakes we were making so I it
really humbled me
how
I say this is a question that um can
sound like a backhanded compliment to
other folks we've had up there and so I
don't mean it that way at all but I
spent most of my career working with
attorneys they've they're they have a
very particular way of experience in the
world the world there's such a gift to
the world and it's rare that I see
somebody sit in a room on something as I
would say as simple as the baby steps
and and not over complicated and settle
the way back and go oh man I was wrong I
think that's a that's us tell me about
that
so that's the beauty of the baby steps
they're so simple they're not easy but
they're very simple and baby Step Zero
which you guys gloss over all the time
that was my problem I did I couldn't
stop spending especially on our home
equity line of credit which is how I
funded all of our acquisition of rentals
gotcha wow so how much was on the HELOC
um probably about a hundred part of that
part of that rental debt was actually on
our helog but I just associated with the
rentals so what is your financial
picture like now with the properties and
your primary and all that
so we have about 2 million in paid for
Real Estate
our house is 300 of that his Warehouse
is 600 of that and that was our baby six
baby step six item and that's not even
touching your retirement correct so
we're talking so you got many benefits
two million dollars for the house is you
have your own paid off house
Warehouse right correct on it's pretty
awesome now a lot of you guys are so
calm good job these people no I'm
shaking now when you actually say those
numbers I mean does that not just Boggle
your mind and your kids are watching all
this yeah if we could if we could just
get them not to be Knuckleheads like we
were and keep them on the right track
they'll be set well you've probably
heard me say over and over
um we often want to know like what are
the right things to say to kids
don't listen to they watch right and
they have a ringside seat to two people
saying absolutely no more so you were
spending willy-nilly
um a couple of years ago
and now you're in a place where you can
kind of spend willy-nilly intentionally
but you can kind of spend what you want
to spend now because y'all are
multi-millionaires and you're making a
couple hundred grand every year
um
what's the difference in your marriage
what's the difference in your psychology
because the actions are going to look
very similar the context is going to be
completely different now
so we've been married 11 years and we
were we were both independently um
successful in our own right and so we
never
really focused on doing things together
so that really changed when we took the
FPU and by the way we've taken FPU four
times
um we just kept taking it it doesn't
cost anymore right no you just keep
taking it and it kept us focused and on
track while we were you know we go you
know
meet different people that were in
different situations and all that it was
really great coordinators
um Ben Greg Ronnie and Michelle shout
out to them so what do you say to in and
George gets this a lot to those who are
35 and younger who are super obsessed
with having this magical unicorn called
passive income and they go buy a whole
bunch of rental properties
um and they leverage themselves to the
hilt but they have this magic called
Cash Flow and they think that's solving
all the world what would you tell them
because you see y'all played that game
there's no nothing passive about being a
landlord I managed all our properties
and it about drove me insane you manage
your properties on top of being a lawyer
oh wow yeah she's a big deal yeah I
believe it so what do you tell people
the key is to getting out of debt
because you guys had a mountain and you
made some sacrifices what is the one
thing the biggest thing is budgeting
whether you make a hundred dollars a
month or a hundred thousand dollars a
month
um I used to As Long As I would put my
ATM card in and I got money or if I
would buy something and it was fine I
was like I got money I'm good as long as
money in the account I don't care what I
spent now knowing where everything's
going it's it's pretty neat and
especially being out of debt it's like
wow what are we gonna do with this it's
a good problem to have oh yeah
you guys are amazing what was your
what's your favorite fight
favorite fight the favorite fight y'all
had over 23 months trying to pay all
this off oh it was more we're both so
competitive that when you know we put
everything in the app and it said it's
going to take you 48 months and we were
like nah that ain't happening it was
just like you know hey look we got to
find some more money we gotta we gotta
we gotta find this and then he started
selling properties you're like there's
some money exactly wow did you sell the
ones that were the biggest pain yes
let's get rid of those ones that's smart
those were actually the ones that
appreciated the greatest so it was a
no-brainer it paid off you guys are
incredible I mean these numbers are just
staggering yeah and the best part is you
you did it in a way that is peaceful now
and I'm just I'm just it's inspirational
so thank you so so much
um
we're gonna give you the the live and
give bundle here which is a copy of baby
step millionaire I guess you can just
write a new chapter and if you'd like to
just tell your story because y'all are
there and then some and a copy of Total
Money Makeover for you to give away to
somebody that you care about as well as
a subscription to
um Financial Peace University so you can
give that away as well
multi-multi-millionaires you guys don't
owe anybody anything you know what you
can do tomorrow whatever you want man
whatever you want you can a client can
come in and you can be like I don't know
John that's the thing I wanted to tell
you about is not only did it free up a
lot of margin our budget it it gave me
the opportunity to free up a lot of
margin in my schedule because I was
suffering self-diagnosed of course with
high functioning anxiety there you go
and um I was to the point where I wanted
to quit but I knew I couldn't quit and
leave him with all this debt so I don't
want to quit anymore I just don't want
to I want to work as hard exactly amen
Mark and Jenny paid off 700
000 in 23 months selling some property
and making 250 to 300 000 count it down
let's hear your debt free screen one two
three we're debt free
[Music]
oh
they did it and you can too this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
today's scripture of the day is
Philippians 2 4.
instead of each person watching out for
their own good watch out for what is
better for others
Charles Dickens writes no one is useless
in this world who lightens the burden of
another I love that I love it all right
let's go to Joshua in Huntsville Alabama
what's up Joshua
hey how's it going guys outstanding man
what's happening
okay so uh my wife and I are on a baby
step six and uh I'm curious if it's
frivolous to get uh braces uh you know
Orthodontics
how much are the brace is going to cost
uh fifty three hundred dollars why would
you
think it's frivolous is it just purely
cosmetic are you having headaches or no
no yeah that's what I'm saying I mean uh
there's a little extra wear on my you
know teeth or whatever uh that you know
I it's not like it's a it's a ton but
it's something I mean I've been wanting
since I was a kid anyway to get braces
and never got him as a kid
um and you know the the orthodontist
said it helped with my wear a lot and
maybe jaw jaw pain but it's not so much
as to where it's a medical needs you
know it's mostly cosmetic well we can
free you today you're gonna get braces
my friend it is not frivolous at all do
you have the money to do this
yeah yeah yeah we do uh we uh we have
and of course we'll be paying in cash so
awesome hey Joshua
like spend some money on yourself man
um have you guys been real focused on
this house payment
so uh it's it's a little bit of uh I say
we're still kind of holding on sticker
shot because we moved a few months ago
and uh sold our sold our old house
um right now the reason another another
big reason we want to get it out of the
way is that we're still paying PMI on it
um because we gotta we had a lower down
payment because we hadn't sold the uh
our first house yet so
cool well in the baby steps when you get
past baby step three you move from
intense to intentional and so as long as
you guys have a plan to pay it off in
under 15 years you get to live your life
save for vacations safe for braces save
for home upgrades upgrade the cars as
long as you're doing it in cash I've got
to know man I I know this is it's kind
of a cut and dry call like of course go
get braces man
um
where did you come to believe that you
weren't worth five thousand dollars or
something you've wanted to do for 20 or
30 years
uh it's more I probably feel less
pressure if we didn't have you know we
literally didn't have PMI on that on the
mortgage right now and even then it's
just one of those things of where well
you know here in uh I'd say probably
projecting out about 10 years or less
we'd have the house paid off anyway so
you know it I've been waiting this long
for them waiting a little longer it
doesn't seem like a bad idea but at the
same time you know this is
and maybe
um maybe a little bit extra confidence
you've you've been looking for for that
long
um we'll get you that raise right
yeah possibly let's hope let's hope that
never make financial decisions on that
kind of hope but
um yeah braces are life-changing go get
braces did you have braces oh yeah up
through a freshman sophomore year high
school in college yeah I I promise you I
don't think I smiled up until then yeah
and it changed my face yeah it changed
how I my posture changed yeah I've had
issues with my teeth my whole life and
so yeah I I I just hear this and I think
man go get him go get him right now
you're working fantastic all right uh
let's go to Lauren in Minneapolis what's
up Lauren
hi
um so basically my question is I'm
currently a college student and I have a
thousand dollar emergency fund and I'm
debt free but my question is I'm going
to grad school in the fall should I
continue my thinking fund to pay through
grad school or should I save a three to
six months emergency fund before that
what are you going to grad school for
School counseling yes
hey be one of the good ones will you
I I will okay fantastic so let me hear
these two options option number one is
you get an emergency fund but then you
have no money to pay for your masters
yes meaning you have to take out student
loans
yes I think you know what option we're
gonna take we're going to cash flow the
Masters and any money left over becomes
the emergency fund
and if you have an emergency that's more
than a thousand dollars we're simply
going to pause and stack up cash and
sell stuff and get side jobs and do
whatever we have to do to cover the
emergency but then we're back on track
cash flowing the Masters how much is the
master is going to cost
uh for the three years it's about thirty
two thousand dollars okay so about 10
grand a year
yep and you're gonna start working today
to start saving up 10 grand
uh no I've already started saving I have
about 20 000 saves I'm putting away 200
a week oh my gosh you have a thousand
dollars in the emergency fund be of 20
in a savings account
yes who are you fantastic so you just
have 12 to go and then once that's
sitting there we can start saving up for
an emergency fund on top of that
okay so that's like you would suggest
like I don't need the
three to six months yeah like just
continue the cash flow and just get out
of school debt free if an emergency
truly happened I would dip into that
savings to pay for it because you still
have time before the next bill hits for
your Masters and I didn't in my master's
program but in my two doctorate programs
I took a semester off at least in every
one life happens somebody gets sick
somebody gets work gets busy things
happen so
um it's different than undergrad
sometimes there's a there's a pace to it
and I know sometimes you go in as a
cohort and it kind of locks you in there
but but yeah yeah head in there with
your head held high you you are going to
be one of the rock stars yeah it's
amazing good grief George I want
I want people like Lauren in the school
system helping our kids
with their challenges yeah when you're
not worrying about your student loans
you can be fully present and when you're
the kind of person it reminds me of you
like I'm just gonna put 200 in account
every day of my every month of my life
and then I've got twenty thousand
dollars in that could grieve all right
let's take one more let's go out to Anna
in Flagstaff what's up Anna how we doing
hi I'm good
um my question is is there anything that
we should be doing right now instead of
just waiting for our credit score to
disappear it's been two years since we
paid off our mortgage it's been a year
and a half since our last like open
credit card account wow and you're
checking the score what's it at today
so my score is completely gone
indeterminable my husband's is at 5 50.
so I guess that's where we're a little
confused have you pulled his credit
reports from all three bureaus
we have um from two of them
um all the account show paid and closed
um yeah interesting
I mean you can try the third one I don't
know what would be holding it up unless
he has some kind of open account or he
may be reporting payments like utility
bills by accident through one of these
sites like Credit Karma
and that can keep your score alive and
so I would make sure to log into every
site he can remember using to see if
anything's being reported
and and I want to ask you a question but
I'm going to actually ask it to George
um
why does it matter is it just fun to see
it at zero I mean you guys don't plan on
going into more debt do you are you
getting a mortgage soon
we we think within the next three years
we're going to reevaluate the house that
we're in if we want to move if we want
to stay in our city we will have to get
a mortgage we are saving money
um but we just can't make that jump
quite with what we have okay
well one thing that could happen is they
use your income and your non-score to
get the loan would you qualify on your
own
no I'm
just okay so this would largely be on
his well I'm going to do some digging to
figure out what the holdup is because a
year and a half to two years is far too
long generally it's six to 12 months
nothing disappears so my thinking is he
may have forgotten what happened with
mine yeah because yours was six to 12
months
yeah my guess is there's some little
dinky account sitting out somewhere that
he forgot to officially close or there's
some Bill being reported but 550 means
that something is amiss because if he
something was reported like a utility
bill that was paid on time it would give
you a good score and 550 just seems too
low
so there's some more digging to do I
would get back with the credit bureaus
and check in with them and check all the
websites he's ever signed up for and do
some homework there
and hopefully by the time you guys buy
the house that thing is long gone and
you do manual underwriting with the no
score alone George great show today you
too man good to thank Kyle and Zach and
James and Ben and Christian in Austin
well thank you America for listening to
us hey be kind take care of yourself
take care of each other this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your